as you probably heard and some of you
have reported a missile was launched a
little while ago from North Korea I will
only tell you that we will take care of
it we have general mattis in the room
with us and we've had a long discussion
on it it is a situation that we will
handle but the bottom line is it's a
continued effort to build a threat serve
a ballistic missile threat that
endangers world peace regional peace and
certainly the United States thank you
and we will take care of that situation
that was the president Secretary of
Defense James Madison to North Korea's
launch of yet another ballistic missile
earlier today here at the very latest in
Washington ed Henry 50 minutes has now
spoken to the Prime Minister of Japan
and the president of South Korea to stay
on top of this because as you noted
missile experts say this is how big it
is this shows North Korea can now launch
a missile that puts every single
American city in its range that's
because while North Korea had previously
fired two intercontinental ballistic
missiles this one went higher than the
others shot off the west coast of North
Korea flew 2,800 miles into space for a
total of 50 minutes that's 10 times
higher than the orbit of NASA's space
station before falling just 280 miles
off the shores of Japan that led vice
president Mike Pence just a few moments
ago in a speech to warned Pyongyang not
to test this American president and this
American military the Kim regime in
North Korea would do well not to test
the resolve of this president or the
capabilities of the armed forces of the
United States of America as president
Trump said today we will take care of
the situation all options are on the
table and we will continue to marshal
the full resources of the United States
to bring economic and diplomatic
pressure to bear until North Korea
it's nuclear and ballistic missile
programs once and for all and just a few
moments ago the President issued a
warning to Democratic leaders in
Congress that he does not want a
government shutdown tweeting that it is
more important than ever that the
military be fully funded John all right
ed Henry live in Washington tonight
thank you joining us now with reaction
Fox News national security strategist
former deputy assistant to the president
Sebastian Gorka we've discussed in
detail not a lot of good options here
it's going to be taken off the pad next
time take it out of the sky as it's
launched and then potentially all hell
breaks loose and we'd have to take out
all their sights correct a great danger
great peril there is great peril but in
fact it's North Korea that has escalated
apparel and at some point the president
will have to take action
secretary manish has been very clear
today this is a direct threat to the
United States and we cannot wait until
the next missile lands on US soil
whether it's Guam or whether it's the
continental US there's there's three
very special issues here short at some
point the credibility of the United
States is put in question the president
has shown leadership whether it's in
Syria with the cruise missile strikes
whether it's the 21,000 pound bomb in
Afghanistan we need to maintain that
credibility to assure our allies and our
friends like Japan secondly there's the
issue of other regimes cannot be
encouraged to behave the way North Korea
is this is a very very bad example to
set for others and lastly Shaun there
has to be a cost for threatening the
United States of America I'm not an
interventionist I know you're not an
interventionist and I know because I
work for him the president is not an
interventionist but if you threaten us
if you're a teen pop bully
like the regime in North Korea and
little Kim then sooner or later you will
pay for your threats that's where we
have reached today Shaun but I would
expect this is not going to be a
protracted conflict this will be massive
and overwhelming a use of force but
there's risks nuclear fallout if we hit
their nuclear facilities
what is Kim Jong Un's reaction does he
fire at Japan does he fire at Guam or
Hawaii or South Korea obviously in Seoul
look the the United States of America is
the most powerful nation on God's earth
it's the most powerful nation we have
ever seen in American history by
comparison North Korea may be a nuclear
state but is it is a lilliputian the
president has said it secretary Madison
said it we will destroy you and we're
not talking about the North Korean
people we're talking about the regime so
we can do amazing things if we are
pushed to do so we don't want to the
president told me one day in the Oval
Office just the two of us I do not want
to go to war in Korea but sooner or
later you make threats that are explicit
and you must be dealt with but it will
not be nice it will be the last resort
agreed and not a favorable but it will
happen and they will invite it at this
point well said dr. Barker thank you
when we come back